"Life moves pretty fast.
If you don't stop and look around once in
a while, you could miss it."
Well, Ferris Bueller's Day Off moves pretty
fast, too.
Perhaps everyone has seen it so many times
that they didn't stop and look around and
realize that there are a lot of baffling events
in the movie.
One of Ferris’ earliest schemes involves
securing a car for the day.
Ferris tells us
"I asked for a car, I got a computer."
...as a way of explaining why he doesn’t
have wheels of his own.
The problem is that his computer is one of
the many expensive toys that fill his bedroom.
In addition to a computer cool enough to be
connected to the web in the mid-80s, Ferris'
room is also stuffed with a slick sound system
and even a synthesizer he puts to particularly
good use.
Throw in the classic electric guitar and he's
got quite a bit of money laying around.
Sell your stuff, Bueller!
After fooling his parents with a fake illness,
Ferris' next big task is convincing his best
friend Cameron Frye to join him on his day
off.
Ironically, Cameron is already out of school
for the day, home sick in bed for real.
Ferris doesn't believe Cameron, noting his
hypochondriac
tendencies.
But Cameron does seem to be quite ill, so
much so that he barely feels like moving.
Somehow, Ferris is able to rouse him and bring
him along on the trip, and just like that,
Cameron is fine.
He goes from lying in bed to hanging out at
a Chicago Cubs game.
Not once during the day do we see Cameron
becoming dizzy, trying to nap, or knocking
back some DayQuil.
He was either faking it, or he was miraculously
cured.
Ferris invites Cameron along, in part, because
he needs a car.
They could just use Cameron's, but Ferris
is too greedy for that.
He wants to spend his day on the town in style,
and has his heart set on stealing Cameron’s
father’s car: A limited edition 1961 Ferrari
convertible.
It's a pretty sweet ride, and so valuable
that Cameron’s Dad doesn't even drive it.
"He just rubs it with a diaper."
Despite the car’s value, though, there’s
little to no security for it.
It's just sitting there, without any protection,
in the garage, which Cameron and Ferris can
just walk into.
It's almost as if Mr. Frye wants it to get
stolen.
Ferris covers his tracks at his house with
a dummy, a complex pulley system, and a tape
playing snoring sounds.
By comparison, his scheme to get his girlfriend,
Sloane Peterson, out of school for the day
is surprisingly low-tech.
It starts with a phone call from Cameron posing
as Sloane's father, claiming her grandmother
died.
Ferris and Cameron then head to the school
to grab Sloane.
When Ferris arrives, he has to disguise himself
as her father by wearing an oversized trench
coat and old-fashioned hat.
Somehow dean of students Mr. Rooney is fooled
by the lazy ruse, even after Ferris and Sloane
share a long, wet kiss.
One of the first things Ferris does on his
day off is take Cameron and Sloane to an extremely
fancy restaurant.
He doesn’t have a reservation, so he steals
someone else's from the restaurant’s list.
For this scheme, he chooses to pose as Abe
Froman:
"The Sausage King of Chicago."
The restaurant’s host is, of course, extremely
skeptical of Ferris' claim.
Ferris works around him by having Sloane call
the restaurant and describe him as Froman.
Somehow, it works, and the baby-faced teen
who is obviously not a meat magnate gets his
table.
One of the most famous scenes in Ferris Bueller's
Day Off is the parade sequence, but there's
a lot about the scene that’s hard to understand.
It's a big cultural event that shuts down
several downtown city blocks, but it's somehow
held in the middle of a weekday.
The heart of the scene is a bit baffling,
too.
Huge parades are highly secured, but this
one just lets some random teen up onto a float
to lip-sync to an old Wayne Newton song?
And why does the float have a microphone anyway?
It's not hooked up to any kind of sound system.
This all leads to a synchronized dance number
set to "Twist and Shout."
It's a little more realistic that Ferris would
know that song, but it's not realistic at
all that a bunch of people have put together
dance routines to go along with this otherwise
completely spontaneous performance.
Ferris plans his day off so it’s packed
with extremely fun activities.
He and his friends go to the Sears Tower,
the Art Institute of Chicago, a fancy lunch,
a Chicago Cubs game, and even a parade.
One problem with packing all that into one
day is that there's no way Ferris, Cameron,
and Sloane could fit it all in with the limited
time they've got.
It's mid-morning by the time Ferris convinces
Cameron to come with him, then he has to jailbreak
Sloane from school, and then drive into the
city.
Once they're in the city, they have to leave
the car in a garage.
Factoring in travel time between activities,
plus setbacks like traffic, there's no way
Ferris is getting back to the suburbs before
his parents.
The villain of the film is dean of students
Ed Rooney, and he both hates and obsesses
over Ferris Bueller.
The thing is that Rooney actually has a good
reason, noting that Ferris...
"He gives good kids bad ideas."
It's Rooney's job to keep the student body
in line and in class, something Ferris doesn't
help with.
He has so many absences that it's a problem.
Rooney knows this, and even sees the evidence
of Ferris covering his tracks by hacking school
records.
So Rooney spends the movie tracking Bueller
to prove the kid isn't really sick.
He goes through a lot of nonsense to catch
Bueller in the act of skipping school…which
means he's really just a guy trying to do
his job.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.